there's an update there's a brandon
sanderson announcement that we don't
know anything about but we were uh
informed more or less that do you know
anything about this no no i have no idea
what this is i
have been lying to you
and it is time for me to admit the truth
i've acted with extreme irresponsibility
have you not been writing brandon
because i accidentally wrote an extra
novel oh my secret god
i apologize i couldn't i knew it i knew
those were all responsible
it might be said he's the only one who
says
i got more done during the painting i
wrote another book i knew it was i added
on to my workflow because that was so
overwhelming
no well
maybe not the entire oh my god
if you leave me alone too long i will
start telling stories
as irrevocable as
what pie you expect to happen another oh
my god and
i might have gone a little overboard you
think
i've written
five extra novels in the last two years
this is on top i know don't roll your
eyes at me
you deal with isolation and quarantine
in your way i'll deal with it in mine
yeah by making us look like a failure
while we've been watching inventing anna
this guy has been writing like 10 books
like you know what i would like
i want his books but you know what i
want more his jeans
that was that was very interesting and
i'm very excited for our year of
sanderson that's that was not expect i
was thinking maybe it was like movie
option or something like that but this
is like he got us all right honestly
though
it wasn't like 110 percent goddess
because i'm like
he probably has an extra book when he
got us is when he said oh no i have
extra extra book thanks for watching
everyone bye thanks bye